BACK.
>> Jason: BATS, THANK YOU FOR
THEIR PART AND WILL COME BACK TO
YOU.
I WOULD BRING BACK CONGRESS ON
METALS, CONGRESSMEN, WHEN YOU
SEE THIS OUT THERE, THESE ARE
PEOPLE IN MINNESOTA THAT ARE
POLICE OFFICERS.
THEY'RE ATTACKING PEOPLE OF
THEIR OWN NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS
AND LOVED ONES.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> WHAT A COUPLE MINUTES MAKES.
THEY'RE HONORING THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND GIVING THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DO, IN A FEW
MINUTES LATER YOU JUST IT
APPEARS TO BE HOSTILITY AND
REALLY AN UNRULY CROWD.
LISTEN, THIS IS ALL ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY CAN TRY TO
INTIMIDATE A FUTURE TRUMP RALLY
SUPPORTER AND GOERS AND IT'S
AWKWARD TO HAPPEN, YOU'VE SEEN
THIS, TIME AND AGAIN WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE OUR     RESPECT OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU CAN
TURN TO VIOLENCE ACCOMMODATE
YOUR CAUSE.
>> Jason: I THINK THE
ELECTION, DONALD TRUMP HAS MADE
A POSITION THAT'S VERY
PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT, YOU LOOK AT
IMMIGRATION ISSUES OUT THERE.
WANT TO ABOLISH I.C.E., THERE'S
CERTAINLY BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
THEM, THEY BEEN CALLING THEM ALL
KINDS OF NAMES ACROSS THE WAY.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, TO SEE THIS,
THIS ELECTION IS STILL A YEAR
AWAY AND YOU'RE SEEING WHAT KIND
OF VIOLENCE THAT ARE BREAKING
OUT.
AND FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO EXPRESS THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS, THE MAYOR IN THE
SITUATION CERTAINLY DIDN'T HAVE
A GREAT WHAT DIRECTION WHEN YOU
HEARD WHAT THE MAYOR WAS SAYING
ABOUT THE TRUMP PENDING VISIT?
>> THE MIRROR, UNBELIEVABLE
PARTISAN INSTEAD OF A PUBLIC
SERVANT AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HIM TRYING TO CHARGE THE
SECURITY DETAIL, FAR AND ABOVE
WHAT THE PREVIOUS EVENTS HAVE
BEEN CHARGED, I THINK IT JUST,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IT FOR
WHAT IT IS.
YOU KNOW, A CITY MAYOR THAT
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THIS PRESIDENT
OR PROBABLY DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND NOT SUPPORTIVE.
TRYING TO MAKE A POLITICAL POINT
INSTEAD OF SERVING THE PUBLIC,
NOT ONLY THERE IN MINNEAPOLIS
BUT WE SEE THAT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE THE
MESSAGE OF FREEDOM AND HOPE TO
ALL AMERICANS FROM
COAST-TO-COAST FROM MAINE TO
FLORIDA AND FROM NEW YORK TO
CALIFORNIA AND IN BETWEEN.
WE SHOW THEM THE DIFFERENCE, YOU
KNOW, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICA, THEY RESPECT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND APPRECIATE
THE RULE OF LAW AND DO NOT
ENDORSE LAWLESSNESS.
>> Jason: I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE ISSUES
COME UP WITH ARE TRYING TO DO IS
OPPRESS PEOPLE FROM COMING OUT
AND TRY TO EMBARRASS PEOPLE AND
MAKE THEM FEEL SHAMEFUL FOR
COMING OUT AND SUPPORTING TRUMP
IN NUMBERS.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, THE PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW IN MIDWEST AND
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE NOT
GOING TO BE SHUT DOWN BY A BUNCH
OF ANTIFA MEMBERS AND SOME OTHER
HOODLUMS WOULD BE OUT THERE
TRYING TO SUPPRESS THEM.
THEIR BASIC HUMAN RIGHT OF
PARTICIPATING IN ELECTION AND
BEING ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES.
OF CONGRESSMAN, I GOT ONE OTHER
THING, ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
IS A DISCUSSION NO WEATHER THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER, I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN USE THAT
TERM ACCURATELY, BUT AS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, SHOULD THIS
PERSON HAVE TO TESTIFY IN PERSON
OR SHOULD THEY DO WHAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED WHICH IS ALLOW THEM
TO TESTIFY BASED ON WRITTEN
QUESTION?
>> NO, LISTEN, WE HAVE EXPENSE
WITH ITS, WHERE THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE COMING
OF THE JURISDICTION OVER
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER PROTECTION.
THE REASON WHY IT'S A STATUTE IS
SO THAT WHEN THEY BECOME PUBLIC
BUT THEY DON'T GET RETALIATED IN
THE END.
TO HAVE ANONYMOUS ASK QUESTIONS
VIA IS NOT WHAT OUR GOVERNMENT
IS SET UP TO DO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WANTS TO COME
FORWARD, THEY HAVE TO BE
IDENTIFIED AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE
PROTECTION THEY NEED TO BE
CROSS-EXAMINED TO TO SEE WHAT
THE MOTIVATION.
PARTICULARLY, THERE IS A BIAS
FOR A PARTISAN SAMPLING.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> Jason: I DON'T KNOW IF
CONGRESS MEANT, YET THE FEEDBACK
WE ARE ABLE TO SEE HERE ON
CAMERA.
BUT, WE HAVEN'T SEEN YET ARE THE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS COMING OUT OF O
TRUMP SUPPORTERS COMING OUT OF T
TRUMP SUPPORTERS COMING OUT OF F
BUILDING TRADE IS SHOWING
PROTESTERS, PEOPLE AND MACS,
PEOPLE CAN WEAR MASKS BUT THEY
DON'T SEEM TO BE, HEY, FRIENDLY
WELCOME TO MINNEAPOLIS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
WHAT DIRECTION WHEN THESE
PICTURES COME ACROSS?
>> IT'S NOT THE WELCOME WAGON
FOR OUR SURE, LISTEN, WHEN WE
HAVE THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY AND
THIS KIND OF HOSTILE ACTIVITY,
IT'S REALLY NOT WHAT OUR COUNTRY
WAS FOUNDED ON.
IT WAS THE FREEDOM TO EXPRESS
OURSELVES, BUT WE NEED TO DO IT